[Music]
hey
bet they thought they're gonna get away
with this huh
excuse me brittany and kayla didn't make
it to the dance camp
didn't the school call you i no kayla's
sick i kept her home this weekend
i was sure they were doing this together
you know they're with their secret plans
no way what dad pull over it's brit what
are you doing here
i'm going to that stupid ballet thing
duh
you think i could talk to kayla her dad
took her to the doctor did she call me
when she's back of course
you need to tell her dad that you don't
know where she is no
hey what happened to your face looks
like you got hit is there a bathroom
nearby
can we pull over now
[Music]
i'm scared she can't be trusted to talk
to brittany's dead
get down where's your friend oh
whatever this game is that you're
playing it's over where's britney gonna
puff me
get out of here i'm going to the
how do police want to do something
really fast
that second degree murder
there's something wrong with her she was
such a happy little girl okay this
friend
her father came by the house acting
strange did bernie ever talk about her
father
she told me that he hits her
you release your temper with your kid
who told you this
does he really hit her no yes i learned
from the best
[Music]
whatever you want to believe
what don't look at me like that
[Music]
you